[Music]
cyanobacteria have a deceiving sense of
the understated about them compared to
some of the complex organisms we have
featured on journey to the micro cosmos
these Bluegreen bacteria seem almost
basic in their morphology and habits
they glide divide and photosynthesize oh
[Music]
and they get eaten a bunch too but you
do not need to be complicated to be
important ecosystems are built on
primary producers like cyanobacteria the
energy they translate from the Sun into
chemical stores gets passed up the food
chain sustaining life of all sizes and
long ago some eukaryotes gained their
own photosynthetic abilities by
absorbing cyanobacteria an endosymbiotic
event had set the stage for the
evolution of plants and plants are a
pretty big deal cyanobacteria however
are more than just a prologue for the
story of complex life forms you might
say they are the creative forces behind
that tail
billions of years ago these tiny
seemingly innocuous organisms brought
something new to the planet an
innovation that would create massive
changes in their environment and set the
stage for eons of remarkable life to
come this is the story of the great
oxidation event and how in the process
of destroying the world as it existed
cyanobacteria created the earth and
we've know it now the bulk of this tale
takes place about 2.5 million years ago
at the end of the Archaean Eon that had
started about 1.5 billion years before
this vast stretch of time included huge
milestones for our planet including the
early days of the micro cosmos but the
Archaean earth looked very different
from ours the planet's crust was
stabilizing and the oceans were filled
with dissolved iron most importantly
though the world was anoxic meaning it
had almost no oxygen and because life
reflects the environment it fills the
earliest creatures on our planet were
anaerobic microorganisms built to
withstand and thrive in an oxygen 'less
environment some of these organisms may
have been phototrophic but their
photosynthetic machinery relied on iron
and sulfide in place of water similar to
bacteria like thioester Ilham that
thrive in anoxic conditions today but
for all of the dramatic changes in earth
and in life that took place during the
Archean Eon the real transformation was
only just beginning
[Music]
we don't know quite when cyanobacteria
emerged just that it's some time before
2.5 billion years ago and when they did
cyanobacteria brought something new to
the photosynthetic mix they used light
to split water into its chemical
components hydrogen which could then be
used to make other energy storing
compounds and oxygen which was released
into the environment as a waste product
this simple chemical reaction is the
source of the great oxidation event
which you might also hear called the
great oxygenation event an accumulation
of oxygen in a previously anoxic world
that reaction would go on to become one
of the most important ones to life the
source of the very oxygen you are
breathing now and remarkably
cyanobacteria were not just the first
organisms to evolve oxygenic
photosynthesis as far as we know on our
planet anyway they are the only
organisms that do so other
photosynthetic bacteria don't produce
oxygen and the eukaryotic organisms that
gained the capacity for photosynthesis
did so by co-opting the talents and
machinery of endosymbiotic cyanobacteria
and as wonderful as that is now back at
the end of the Archaean Eon oxygenic
photosynthesis didn't just make
cyanobacteria unique it made them
catastrophic oxygen is great if you are
evolved to tolerate it and to use it but
for the anaerobic microorganisms
specifically evolved for a world without
oxygen this new fangled molecule was
toxic the species that survived the
great oxidation event likely did so by
finding oxygen Liszt's sank
- Aries and meanwhile cyanobacteria
continued pumping out oxygen yes they
are tiny and the amount of gas they
produces even tinier but with hundreds
of millions of years and many many
organisms all of those reactions added
up affecting not only the lives of their
fellow microbes but also the chemistry
and climate of the entire planet for one
cyanobacteria might be responsible for
setting off a series of ice ages as they
consumed carbon dioxide and produced
oxygen that reacted with methane that
cut down on the planet's stock of
greenhouse gases and dropped
temperatures to glacial levels as you
might imagine these early ice ages were
not particularly hospitable for life
including for cyanobacteria coupled with
the anaerobic microbes that died due to
all that oxygen in the atmosphere the
great oxidation event is responsible for
an extinction so ancient that we don't
have the tools or physical evidence to
even fully describe it but life still
managed to endure and as it did the
oxygen produced by cyanobacteria would
go on to form our planet's ozone layer
shielding the survivors from dangerous
ultraviolet wavelengths of light
moreover the availability of oxygen in
the water and air would go on to make
aerobic metabolism possible providing
organisms more energy than anaerobic
metabolism ever could and thus the
capacity for more complex life this
intertwined story of destruction and
evolution is built on evidence
scientists have gathered from geological
and biological sources some parts are
in rocks like the banded iron formations
formed by oxygen reacting with iron in
the ocean and other parts are encoded in
the genes of modern-day cyanobacteria
whose sequences and machinery elucidate
what their ancient counterparts may have
looked like
[Music]
but characterizing the lives of microbes
that existed billions and billions of
years ago is really really hard
especially because we haven't uncovered
many Archaean fossils one recent paper
begins with the following confession
writing about early microbial evolution
is a daunting task so it was possibly
unwise to agree to do it and as you dig
through the research on the subject that
honest evaluation rings true there are
many gaps in our understanding of the
great oxidation event gaps built on
unanswered fundamental questions like
how did photosynthesis even evolve we
alluded to one of the most important
gaps earlier it's the question of when
cyanobacteria first appeared and that
question is key to understanding how
they caused the great oxidation event if
that event began shortly after the
evolution of cyanobacteria and oxygenic
photosynthesis then it all seems
relatively straightforward the
cyanobacteria produced oxygen the oxygen
accumulated and catastrophe ensued but
some evidence suggests that
cyanobacteria emerged well before the
accumulation of oxygen on earth and if
that's the case and we have to ask what
took so long for the great oxidation
event to begin maybe there was a
geological delay of some sort or maybe
oxygenic photosynthesis wasn't the only
cyanobacterial innovation maybe after
their first appearances on the planet
they developed some other trait that
bumped their oxygen production up even
more
one group of scientists investigated
that very possibility and came to a
possible explanation that we don't often
associate with bacteria multicellularity
some modern cyanobacteria species formed
filaments of individual cells a few of
which even take on specialized functions
like nitrogen fixation these scientists
trace the origins of that trait to
before the great oxidation event
so maybe multicellularity allowed
cyanobacteria to not only better contend
with the challenges of their environment
but to produce more oxygen than before
and perhaps this was the added trait
needed to say allow a new kind of
bacteria to take over an entire world a
claim over our planet but they have in
many ways never given up of course that
idea is scientific conjecture built on
the available evidence which means it is
still subject to debate but the
seemingly simple question underlying it
the question of when cyanobacteria
evolved reflects what's so important
about the great oxidation event in
general that questions of biology and
geology and climate are so intertwined
that to understand the history of this
planet we have to piece together the
history of the micro cosmos and if
something as small as cyanobacteria can
set off a catastrophe of extinction and
ice well and what will the planet look
like when we're through with it
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us the Stentor karolius
pins have been restocked there's a link
in the description so you can check that
out thanks to everybody who's sporting
one of their favorite and microorganisms
on their backpack or jacket now and
thank you also to all of these people
who make this show possible so if you
like what we do you can thank them for
that
what a wonderful group of people that
allow us to explore these big weird
mysteries of life on this planet if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James you can check out Jam
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us I bet you can figure
out how to subscribe
[Music]